- Being a CEO or entrepreneur
isn't something that you typically say
that you wanna be when you grow up
when you're younger.
People wanna be basketball
players or like models
'cause it's not very
glamorous to be a CEO.
But we're proving that like it can be fun
and like you can just
be like a normal person.
(quirky music)
I'm Erin.
- And I'm Amelia.
- And we run Shop Jeen together.
- And we're best friends!
- And we're best friends.
- So I started Shop Jeen in
my college dorm room 2012.
And I was workin' retail jobs
and just like kind of frustrated
there wasn't like anything very cool
for my taste online and to shop at.
So Shop Jeen was born.
We were really early to using Instagram
and I like contribute a lot
of our success to Instagram.
Started using it in 2012
when not that many brands
or people were even on it.
If you scroll pass one of our products
you'll see it on the Explore page.
It's like so eye-popping and catchy
that like people definitely
like engage with it.
- And we're really active on
our own personal social media
like Instagram we use a lot.
And yeah we just put like
our kind of our whole lives out there.
And I think our customers and fans
like to relate to us on there.
- Then 2012 I started Shop Jeen
and then Amelia came on January 2013.
- [Amelia] Yeah, so me
and Erin met years ago.
We crossed paths interning
at Alexander Wang
when we liked real fashion, right?
- We read each other's vine,
finish each other's sentences.
We sleep in this bed together.
- [Amelia] Oh yeah.
- It's awesome to be
like business partners,
sisters, best friends, low-key lovers.
- It's almost three years now
and we're not sick of each other yet,
which is pretty crazy.
The first thing that we
produced in-house ourselves
was a line called NETGEAR90
and it's an Internet-inspired
really cool clothing and accessories line.
The aesthetic of NETGEAR90 is just like
Internet everything.
It's inspired by Tumblr.
There's lots of like baseball
caps with like reblog symbols
and you know shirts that say Yes, Daddy?
and things like that.
- If I had to describe my personal style,
it would be hardcore, poser.
I love this shirt.
"I'm retired. Do it yourself."
Obnoxious, annoying.
- I'm wearing a really cool,
double XL dinosaur hoodie.
Ignorant and edgy.
- Mine would be like thirsty
for attention probably.
- These things are pretty cool.
- We should take 'em on the plane.
- Yeah.
We would look like such idiots.
Everyone will love it.
- Perfect.
- Our style changes like so constantly
because we like know about things
before they're big.
We like also discard
them like very quickly
because we're like, ew, we
just saw it like on this person
or like everywhere.
It's not cool anymore.
- Yeah and it's fun, it's fun.
We like dressing fun.
People I feel like know that
we have a sense of humor
and understand like pop culture
and the Internet and stuff.
- We definitely get people all the time
who don't take us seriously
because I mean look at us.
We're in a bed full of pillows.
The fact that we are very nonchalant
and true to ourselves,
we don't change for anyone.
Like I will wear this to any meeting
with any investor or anyone.
There's no one I wouldn't
wear this outfit to.
If that offends you
then I don't think that
we should work together.
The best part about running this business
is the connection that we
have with our customers.
We get comments in Instagram
all the time.
People saying that we have
like changed their lives
that they don't feel like they belong
and that when they come to our website,
they feel like someone understands them.
And to think about what
we're doing in that way
that it's like inspiring people
and like really impacting people's lives
and making them more
comfortable with who they are
able to express themselves through style
and like fit in and like feel like
it's okay to be just who they are
like that is the most rewarding thing
at the end of the day, hands down.
- There's a rumor that we're
lesbians on the Internet.
(laughs) Stop!
So dramatic.
- (laughs) I try.